con más de un millón de votos el
economista rodrigo chávez del partido
progreso social democrático es el
presidente electo de costa rica tras una
jornada electoral tranquila en la que
logró triplicar los votos que consiguió
en primera ronda se trató de una segunda
ronda cuya campaña se centró en
señalamientos negativos hacia ambos
candidatos lo cual impactó en la
participación ciudadana el
abstencionismo llegó al 42 6% el más
alto de la historia del país
incrementándose en dos puntos en
comparación con la primera vuelta chávez
gobernará a partir de mayo junto con una
asamblea legislativa en la que su
partido logró 10 diputados de un total
de 57 por lo que deberá consensuar con
otras bancadas como la más grande que es
la de liberación nacional cuyo candidato
fue derrotado por chávez el presidente
electo invitó a sus adversarios
políticos a trabajar juntos para sacar
adelante al país el ex ministro de
hacienda señalado por la sanción por
acoso sexual que le aplicó el banco
mundial- cuando elaboró allí como
directivo también deberá lidiar con
otros nuevos señalamientos como el
financiamiento de su campaña con
supuestas estructuras paralelas las
cuales no son permitidas por la ley